well we do have more submission for cats
pet cats
rap battle and they're pretty fired like
you said little brow still the champion
because of that he might win forever do
you think we should retire him no no no
you gotta bring the heat man this is a
mile this is a mile yeah this ain't this
is a mile that's chatter do I really
look like cheddar Bob and Oscar Gaucho
at a baby chatter Bob sound self in the
leg a little bit chatter Bob in the
house Doug that's all good no we didn't
have a similar nose kind of do you guys
look up there he is
put a mullet on that picture
that's Theo Doug oh my gosh chatter Bob
what is that man's name Evan Jones look
at that other picture up move up above
right above that one yes you don't fell
on hard times Jesus dude that's like
cane rounds like cocaine Brown dang yeah
shout out chatter Bob that I can't
believe that yeah that's me yes yeah
we're eight mile or breakfast club and
your cheddar Bob let's hear these raps
doc I don't think we should retire he's
the king man you got it you have to
bring such fire to beat [ __ ] brows
fair enough the reigning champ you think
forever no there's a fire today alright
don't say fire got on that kid in the
second round don't say fire make you
feel awkward
this comes from Steven Lacoste
aka Don the [ __ ] is fired on Don King in
a sting fan what's good a longtime
listener love what you boys do for real
y'all make my dad better than episode
drops so thanks Don salute
I appreciate y'all vo my dog I 190
Covington right around the corner
Madisonville seemed that good would yang
brother job Brendan see you ass in the
woollens March 14th
oh yeah doggies get to it I see
everybody's sending in their rap [ __ ] so
I figured I'd do the same y'all let me
know what y'all think let's go off 190
son I'm kind of feeling sued already is
the beat hot nick is an original beauty
denim listening Gang Gang buzz buzz
chatter Bob Circosta
it's Theo von and Brendan Schaub King
and the sting yeah he's confident brah
like like the hoodie Thursday risking
catches loaded the Showtime on knowing
the OD and Brendan be on some narcotic
potion he lives a mixin spill and
openness is an explosion so stay aligned
my Mundek London I can't antidote it I
think your stuff a mister on the King
the channel Hogan and show him how we
walking down inside the Lando roadies
Louisiana born and bred reach up on the
float
look up
look at Brendan babies Lopez open to
that boy you're going busing god I'm
losing focus if it aint other stuff
insane it's a folding bed is this woman
that's please deposit check is on
business let's keep this working in the
bus Lambo beacon Booker up fans I guess
that's us man Dan the [ __ ] this gang
gang buzz buzz - like bie don't be
touching me today some vultures peak the
pedigree a savage P my head busters CTE
dinner is Kristin tree laughing in the
MSE [ __ ] [ __ ] G chin got the recipe
great I said recipe Brendon thinking
stuff to me I can't see him losing until
the day catches chill with the dick
amusement it's all for my art - you're
riding round person and see your faces
on a poster for movement
she was so five and dance with my neck
[ __ ] up like this King and the sting
Wow yeah that [ __ ] was pure fire I don't
know little brown sesame hair cut my
talk you two now yeah I got that see
[ __ ] you got a girl dog you got that
baby cape dude that [ __ ] [ __ ] well
you're gonna grow some seed come on now
get them curls dude dude in Turin when I
was in Canada yeah do not wear hockey
huh me really oh I have a hockey stick
from these [ __ ] that's the only one
god damn that was you the crazy thing
about Don's I would have to go back and
listen again to even get all of it me
too
I actually had him send the lyrics to us
too so we can look through those later
but he's good but this is a familiar
face who also came with me Don going G
the sting records here we go
well that's probably the tenth bet
you're hard on us who try to step inside
a few
ran into these big tail
oh she's just waking up royalty in the
bill
he's that way that lazy Bronson Action
Bronson discovers Brendan when he put
him on me back in the middle of the cage
now you know he's counting steps hopped
up on that stage and he started spare
facts then he got a couple lives and he
knew it was a rap to the game he never
gonna attack we're putting in the raps
and Shawn in the status came up in the
mouthpiece now he's killing on the beach
and spend the weekend on the road and
back to go eat
cut the fear we can crawl the speaking
for y'all caught up on that by you now
he's preaching other people started in
reality and turned it to a fantasy never
could have dreamed how intense the
demography and
party in the back the gang has come down
shoulders got that monkey off the stack
the way with positivity he spreads
across the mat there's little words away
from that he dropped something this lad
he love you dog love you for that
kitty cat looking like a host like hole
smashing each in with that agent Charles
Bronson
like that counselor at the rehab and
they're done man
but still who perronnette top ten
[ __ ] brother disease
be like the before picture before
domestication loose a Public Accounts
[Music]
got a tickle my life
[Music]
their necessity [ __ ] rolling we were
laughing over it but after he said Nick
looks like dead Luke Perry goes no
seriously Nick you look like dead look
boy these were beastie and actually
little brows came in he gave a do we
want to hear it now he gave a full mix
version of his song hundred percent here
we go man it is thick out here we're
losing stay where music studio to the
culture corner
Brennen and Theo fighter and wait I
gotta go and then go hard in the paint I
did not think I am in Flo black rifle
coffee I'm ready to go
I need a sponsor I am a monster about to
open up with this and my concerts for
was contagious browser outrageous
thicker than girls that are Instagram
famous damn okay like I'm fresh off keto
see a red like Andrew Santino every
summer he is like the great Bambino
we're gonna take the case so end the
case Cerritos pursue my DMS a couple of
you try to couldn't beat him quit
playing I mentioned odious you don't
want the smoke like Joey Diaz meaning
y'all edible just got my eyebrows
threaded and I'm feeling incredible Brit
and son hit me up he said it's true loud
in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
and sting this fool like you watch the
speech these already have enough change
and the sting King in the stink
and the stink I stink
[Music]
she's on the stream is pregnant and do
fighter in Creole shout out New Orleans
and shout out to Co Colorado more
specifically Boulder Brendan came in
with the chip on his shoulder but is
still gold and yet still fire if you
don't like King Aniston you're a liar
Brenda's got like a thousand different
hustle wonder bums that noise director
went I here's my fee we hear you loud
and clear your son on the email like
please get me out of here it's way too
loud in here watching the Irishman
eating pizzas drinking half a beer now
under Theo von looking like the type of
dude the trans Arita songs sweet senator
Wes with a snapback on let's hit the
crib enjoy snapchat it's a good we still
mess with you 18:11 Pico Boulevard go
get ahead Derek and Kat y'all doing
great Thursday upload not a minute late
y'all wanted to rap ahead Adam in a
straight brand new studio y'all feelin
great but in Chris Delano in this place
now let's go and get Chinna
[Music]
yeah you can't [ __ ] you can't [ __ ] with
little brows bro those other boys are
nice but that dude brings the bangers I
feel like you need to drop the 97 hot
well we need YouTube to pick a winner
between Don Lacoste the first guy from
Covington and Papa Bear and then we'll
put out to a vote between Austin our
first guy probably four dude I gotta say
this about dawn straight up dawn thank
uh I'll have to listen to Don again
[Laughter]
[Applause]
chatter bombs away I'm over here - don't
Quaid and bails me dude they were so
good they remixed my voice box bro so
weird this dope though man
also Austin little browser Champlin we
put him up a vote against vicious and he
dominated da Matta 85% he took vision
and vicious was the guy with the UH with
the kit with the shirt on right the bass
- vicious was the guy who had like the
screen record and he had like the wave
form around yeah Brow's just says talent
was all three of the guys got talent man
the one guy I love the fact that Don uh
came in which one was done big boy
Don was the first guy okay that's nice I
love that Don came in straight out of
Louisiana although that Papa Bear came
in and he had made fun of his tattoo you
had a man - homeboy I thought it was
great I thought it was good work - it
just I just had some questions all right
carry on some questions that ended in
exclamation point there was no respect
dude and he submitted it to get ripped
up but anyway he came but he like came
back at us I know that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
pretty gay look a mile yeah yeah mom
spaghetti no it's all great it's gonna
be tough to beat [ __ ] little brown
especially with the remix the street
makes
he made for us look man I'm on offense
aside by I think it's the I love I love
Papa Bear I love everything he did I was
fantastic I think it's the Don and
little brown obviously let the fans
decide also I guess make sure you send
me the the remix so you can walk up to I
think we let the fans decide who is um
know who know computer games
growl okay two votes or just at least
one vote right now I got to hear it
again man I can't make a choice
immediately you're on you're not right
now I need to hear it later on I need
hear when I'm by myself or someone I've
had like a relaxing afternoon yeah we
got time we only do this every couple of
weeks so little brows goes hard in the
paint do the president about to get also
there be and their styles are so
different to the fur the Don had a beat
that romana me a little bit oh can you
can you just put a sample of it up again
they each reminded me of a different
kind of kissing family
yeah I think yang Buffalo zoo my culture
culture so you get points with a steel
vaughn and Brenda's job for those
Gribble of danger things and the sting
yeah
me I'm deal win look dealing with can
catches Lodi to show time I'm knowing
the OB and Brendan beyond so what are we
hooking down inside the lair roadies
Louisiana born and bred reaches the flow
look out in the bus lamp will be can put
corrupt fan I guess that's us man Dan
the [ __ ] this gang gang buzz-buzz
till I di II don't be touching me but
keep touching me culture culture today
some vultures peep the pedigree I stab
just be my head busters CTE Derek
twisting tree laughing in the MSE [ __ ]
[ __ ] G chin got the recipe I said
recipe Brendon thinking's testing me but
you'll probably think it mixing deco
with us to your teeth
[Music]
papa bear you rotten Brown Busan and see
your faces don't post the food that's
just a man it's a little browsing him
man I think we throw up between brows
and Don were know between dawn and Oh
help me out Nick put a bear Papa Bear
and let them decide and then one of them
goes up against brows object it's just
too much for me I'm gonna do it it's
waste your time I'm exhausted
you do that this [ __ ] was that a lot of
time I was dancing a lot of time Dan
what else we got that's a lot of work -
yeah shout out to those although that's
a lot of work
[Music]